what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back today with another installment
of our series examining omega level
mutants and today
we're talking about jamie braddock also
known as monarch so jamie braddock was
created by chris claremont herb tremp
and fred creda and first debuted in
captain britain weekly number nine in
1976. now jaime's the oldest child of
the braddock family an aristocratic
family whose financial means
no longer match their social status and
the older brother of the twin siblings
brian who later became captain britain
and then betsy
better known as psylocke now in his
adulthood jaime takes control of
braddock industries and the company
thrives due to his vast financial
knowledge he's also a famous race car
driver because apparently running a
multi-billion dollar corporation was not
interesting enough on his own
you know i wonder how it is that he
became a race car
driver you know i know how he became a
race car driver he used skillshare
yes he did as you guys know i love
skillshare i absolutely love skillshare
those of you guys who don't know
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of aspiring
classes for creatives and curious people
you can explore new skills and develop
existing interests and
get lost in creativity what you guys may
not know is that one of my favorite
creators is a guy named thomasfrank and
thomas frank
has a skillshare program where he
basically teaches you how to be creative
and to be productive
in fact his course is actually called
productivity for creatives build a
system that brings out your best but in
all seriousness given the way the last
year
transpired i've been looking to build up
new skills and just try new things that
either i'd put on the back burner or
just never seem to get around to and now
i'm making time for me and skillshare is
a great place to learn to do that
whether you're looking to get into
photography or you want to create
youtube videos and you got to learn how
to write scripts and how to shoot your
videos and how to edit effectively
skillshare can teach you
all of that stuff and so to get you guys
started the first 1 000 people to use
the link in my description will get a
free trial of the skillshare premium
membership and after that it's only
around 10
a month so make sure you guys go check
them out and let's get back into the
video
so having said all that jamie ultimately
ends up developing a gambling problem
and basically finds himself turned into
a life of crime to pay off his gambling
debts now ultimately jaime ends up
finding himself getting kidnapped by a
guy named dr crocodile who basically
screws with his brain and jaime ends up
going crazy believing everything around
him to be a dream in addition to driving
him crazy the trauma jamie experience
also triggered his mutant powers which
normally activate in mutants during
adolescence but had remained latent in
jaime well into adulthood and it's then
that jaime discovers he has the ability
to warp reality now there are several
characters in marvel comics that can
warp reality but with monarch we
actually get an explanation of how
exactly he's
able to do this so jaime perceives
reality as a series of quantum strings
that he can manipulate tighten loosen or
untie to literally
change the fabric of reality his powers
allow him to alter the size and shape of
objects or people
and alter the memories of others he can
control any form of energy and is able
to create portals that allow him to see
things on the other side of the world or
even into other realities now monarch
has also demonstrated the ability to
increase or decrease the level of
resistance that others have to reality
warping or telepathic attacks
as he did with his sister betsy after
raising her from the dead he also has
superhuman durability and healing
making it nearly impossible to harm him
through conventional means and has even
survived being stabbed
in the head with psylocke psionic blade
without ever flinching now one of the
most impressive feats monarch has
achieved was the creation of the fury a
cybernetic construct capable of mass
destruction now jaime patterned the fury
after a being of the same name
in the parallel reality of earth 238 by
another reality warping mutant named mad
jim jaspers now jaspers created that
version of the fury to destroy all
superpowered beings on his earth except
for himself and eventually succeeded in
killing captain britain after she bailed
on that reality but the fury that jimmy
braddock created seemed to be nearly
identical to the original fury and was
able to emit
extremely powerful energy blasts
equivalent in power to a small star and
is resistant to almost
all damage now when the fury did sustain
damage it was able to restore its body
and was able to produce nanites that
could transform
any nearby technology into an extension
of itself the fury possessed super
strength with
no upper limit and was able to analyze
the abilities of its opponents and
update its defenses
accordingly it took the combined power
of rachel summers
creating a black hole with her
telekinesis and working in tandem with
storm and bishop's energy powers being
channeled into rachel through the x-men
sage who's being kept alive during the
process by drawing on wolverine's powers
to take down
the fury so yeah the fury was capable of
destroying an entire planet and monarch
was able to just
create it at will which is a testament
to his prowess as a reality warper but
perhaps the most impressive thing we've
ever seen him do
is use his reality warping abilities in
the white hot room so the white hot room
serves as the home of the phoenix force
and exists within the imcron crystal
which contains the nexus of all
realities and is the origin of all
matter that exists in all realities
within marvel comics but because it
exists outside
of reality the white hot room should be
impenetrable by reality warpers but
monarch was able to tear the fabric
comprising the room's boundary
and pull psylocke and rachel out of it
and back to their reality
so even though jamie braddock's power is
limited by his sanity
this feat suggests that he is an
extremely adept reality warper which is
why he's designated as a mega level
easily which has recently been confirmed
in jonathan hickman's definitive list of
omega level mutants but having said that
it's a pretty short video let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
and i will catch you all later peace